value to lose my name is Trevor Manuel I
am the minister responsible for planning
in the Republic of South Africa it's a
great opportunity to be sharing with you
hear from Davos and to be able to engage
with you and pick up on the issues that
matter to you clearly the world is in a
very parlous state at the moment coming
out of recession caused largely by
excesses in the financial sector a lot
of emphasis has been placed on the
balance sheets of banks the size of the
deficit of government but the bigger
challenges lie in the impact of the
financial crisis on the lives of very
ordinary working people people have lost
their jobs people who've lost access to
credit to their houses to all manner of
issues major setback in the lives of the
poor so as we deal with issues right now
exists that we as physics